so on Kickstarter these people release
signed called the no phone now we talk
about this a lot also this phone
addiction so there's in the no phone now
it says thirteen thousand dollars there
that they've raised as of this morning
last I saw it's about seventeen thousand
and let's let's show a video of the no
phone before I tell you what it is this
is a video of the new account yeah
that's the video they have on the
Kickstarter that's it a picture and that
they've raised $17,000 all it is is a
piece of plastic that replicates your
phone because we all suffer from this
phone addiction so if you don't want the
actual technology in the pocket and the
ability to Instagram for food at every
freakin meal well this is sort of a way
of weaning you off of that and $17,000
for a piece of plastic and they're gonna
make it and they're gonna send it to
these people
this actually struck me as kind of cool
like it's obviously silly of course but
you know we do a lot on the technology
addiction your phone is on the table
right now I'm sure yours is in your
pocket they they take mine before the
show no I know anything could eat it
yeah
anything could happen at any moment I
know but something do you feel we need
to be weaned off this stuff a little bit
I I definitely I've been saying it for a
couple weeks now I've been trying the
thing where I don't look at my phone in
the morning in bed I get up for a while
I realized well I was 20 minutes and I'm
just looking at my phone I'm off that
I'm off doing it at night but did you
think something like this could actually
help people separate from the digital
world because I mean I'm proud that I
have done that I've run those tests on
myself you know and I don't think I'm
that bad that's the thing so I think I'm
somewhere in the middle where I actually
don't have the urge to always do it but
again when you're on at restaurants
meeting it really does take away from
your interaction with human beings and
this is where we start sawing old people
said you know back in my day we used to
talk to each other yeah yeah and so I
want to avoid coming off like that yeah
because I think there should be a happy
medium but if there's just a blank
plastic thing which I understand is
somewhat of a joke there's a blank last
thing I mean I don't have I don't love
just holding my [ __ ] phone that's
that's the annoying part where the
technology's gonna go is where I don't
have to hold him or I could just put
this screen in front of my face and my
hands can be free that's what like the
holding part is the most annoying part
yeah we want the technology
kind of afraid of our own thoughts at
this point that's what I've noticed like
if you see someone waiting on a corner
for somebody you're going out for dinner
with somebody in the old days and I
don't want to sound like that guy either
but the old days you would just say I'm
meeting you on the corner I'll be there
and then if that person was late well
you didn't have a phone and you'd stand
on the corner and you might think about
some [ __ ] or look around and see some
people and people watch which I still
love to do but now the inclination
immediately is to go to your phone not
have a moment with yourself is that more
that we're addicted to this thing or
we're at the point where we're like
afraid to just have a thought like just
stand there and have a thought I love
that point I I'm with you though Dave
and I I really can do the phone in the
bed anymore after dropped it on my own
face too many times you know you're like
oh and I own your hair but I cry yeah
it's gonna crack my screen I actually
looked at it I considered buying one
it's $15 per phone I was like this is
fun like I'm sure part of it is the game
make up like Oh Christmas stocking
stuffers but they're had there's a lot
to be said about not people numbing
themselves I think I think P means I'm
just gonna I'm not gonna say just
Americans humans like to avoid feeling
feeling pain or sadness or any kind of
vulnerability so this is why we drink
and why we do drugs and why we smoke
because it's a vice it's something to
distract us from ourselves and sometimes
that's not healthy because no matter
what you're distracting yourself from
it's still gonna stay in there it's so
gonna it won't go away how long do you
think you could go without your phone if
we took that phone out of your pocket
you have that big gas phone you may not
be on it all the time but that thing's
like a boat yeah Jesus you vote yeah I'm
having phone yeah something I've tried
to think of this before - um and the
thing is I have gone little stretches
where I actually didn't do it it feels
like an hour - and my phone is filled
with notifications thing where the [ __ ]
are you what's going on where have you
been I'm like oh [ __ ] the girlfriends
I feel like he's married no maybe and
and yeah it's it's just the same amount
of messages I could go a day one day how
long could you go I've been out to lunch
with you it's it's an Instagram in your
I always put that one and I put it down
is that right I'm pretty good about it I
so if it's if it's a date like a normal
day for me I mean literally like right
now I have not looked at my alerts or
whatever I mean I can go for a couple of
hours but you know what I do enjoy I do
enjoy having permission to not be on my
phone so I'm on vacation if I'm going
away if I'm about to hit a flight I love
flying for that reason because even
though there's no gogo Wi-Fi not
available guys sorry eight hours but I
do I do not look forward to landing and
getting 20 emails and 13 text messages
and four voicemails in my butt I like
having the awaiting hey guys on Facebook
hey guys you know please tweet at me
because I'm gonna be away Yeah right
bring us on the air yeah no that's the
thing I feel like we can eliminate some
of the apps you don't have to have
everything that the phone comes with
yeah so I don't I don't have all of my
email connections on there I don't check
it all the time so it can't bother me I
don't assume the notifications when
someone tweets at me or when someone
Facebook's me I have to go find it and
then a lot of those my phone was filled
with apps and I said why are these honey
I've never used any of these I just
eliminated 15 to 20 apps and it just
clears up your space a little bit